first of all it said that Russell Crowe
yeah was the original they wanted him to
be Wolverine is that true absolutely and
Russell Crowe called you and said hey
you ought to go in on this part
he didn't tell Cole may he cold Bryan
Bryan Singer the director said I don't
want to do it but you should look at
this guy right and I was doing Oklahoma
at the time my hair looked like he
always man I had him in my hair you had
afro when I went for the Wolverine
audition I had to put a baseball cap on
and the casting agent said I had nothing
the baseball cap for Wolverine I took it
off you guys here put it back on it is
so weird isn't it because here you know
first of all you have the Australian
accent you know there was a lot they had
to overlook or take a leap of faith with
me was Wolverine plus you knew nothing
about will bring you thought you thought
it was about wolves you thought you were
playing eyes it was I didn't even know I
never heard of x-men I didn't know there
was an animal called a Wolverine I
thought it was like one of those Shazam
it's a made-up like how I began a ball
or something and I came to said after
studying wolves and I had this whole
physicality and I was doing like a
rehearsal in dirt because what he do me
the body man and I said all you know
it's just thinking the Wolves away
they're always smelling and they're
looking down because they're actually
smelling the ground he goes wolves
you're a Wolverine I said well there's
no such thing I guess yeah there is go
to the zoo down the road man there's all
good Borbon down there what do you do
you walked around I know your wife told
you not to take apart your eyes it's
easy it doesn't do the audition yeah she
the Royal National Theatre and you got
freaking claws coming out you know she's
going off three pages right and by the
way this is the only time Deb has ever
been wrong very very clearly a good
advisor yeah yeah but I went for the
audition and I said yeah but Anna Paquin
this is a McKellen Patrick Stewart yeah
you know it's the director of usual
suspects it's got to be more of this you
know I'd only read three pages to it but
isn't the motto or nothing about the
moral of the story that as a as a
performer as an actor hmm
you gotta act you can't you don't know
with these films you don't really have a
crystal ball not to know that you're
gonna end up are you the longest-running
in a series I think the only other guy
is Sean Connery who'd played James Bond
yeah
but you playing a continuing character
in the movies yeah you're one that you
have the most longevity as Wolverine
yeah and it's brilliant wine is no I and
yeah I I always had a young actors like
I don't nobody doing this I said yes yes
yes Michael Caine's the best Michael
Caine always said you guys look one in
ten things you do is a success
everything else is a failure so just say
yes to everything right and just make
sure you got ten things are we done with
Wolverine is that it is it over yep it's
over yeah are you okay
good we're all right I feel good because
I was really proud of that last film and
I blow very good yeah I love I loved
that film yeah thanks man and and and
and I really did decide to finish it
after their conversation I had with
Jerry Seinfeld I asked him my why what
made him quit like what was the last
thing to say this is the last season he
said it's really important if you're in
anything creative to not run the tank
dry because it could actually never get
refilled again like if you could really
overdo it he said so you leave while
there's something in the tank and that
will propel you into the next thing who
knows what the next thing is right it's
good but how do you know when there's
not maybe there is more in the tank it's
just a it's just a gut feeling the
moment he told me that story I was like
oh yeah well you know Sean Connery made
his last James Bond film and then came
back he yes I am he's like [ __ ] what I
said how much money you give me
okay can I reserve so I'll make it a
deal okay if I change my mind I'll tell
you guys right give you permission
believe me it's all really here